fire made flesh such as the nature of
dragons claim the Eastern mystics for
once they may have a point though not
the one they think fire consumes leaving
at its end nought but ash
thus the fate of the Targaryen and their
dragons thousands of years ago
valerian stumbled on the first dragon
eggs in the mountains of the 14 fires
cannot imagine shepherds could hatch
dragon eggs and bind such creatures to
their will but whatever aid they must
have had is lost to history every
educated person knows are the
Dragonlords then conquered most of the
known world breaking the ancient
ghiscari empire enslaving a continent
building roads and bridges that still
stand today though the art that made
them is lost an empire of Marvel's and
misery and now what is left of Valyria a
smoking wasteland ash in time Aegon
Targaryen and his sisters brought their
three dragons who had escaped a doom to
Westeros perhaps thinking to regain his
people's lost glory and so he did on the
field of fire he proved that armies were
no match for dragons at Harrenhal he
proved that mighty castles weren't
either Aegon Targaryen became Aegon the
conquerer first of his name founder of a
dynasty his first act to order his
dragon balerion the black dread to melt
the soles of his beaten foals into his
new Iron Throne
for over a hundred years the Targaryen
dragons cemented their breeders hold on
the Seven Kingdoms if not each
other.when Targaryen for Targaryen in
the Civil War called the dance of the
Dragons an angry mob stormed the dragon
pit that huge now ruined vault with a
Targaryen stable there be
thousands died but through sheer numbers
and madness five of the Targaryen
dragons lay dead by the morning wish was
perhaps too many there after each
generation of dragons grew smaller than
its parents their skulls used to line
the throne room of the red keep in order
of birth the oldest balerion could
swallow an ox hole the last skull was
barely the size of a dog's yet the
Targaryen never stopped trying to revive
their dragons
aerion brightflame drank a draught a
wildfire and burned to death Aegon the
fifth tried to hatch stone dragon eggs
with sorcery and burn to death against
these Aerys the second looks almost
sensible he only burned other men to
death no we hear rumors that the young
Daenerys Targaryen has hatched three
dragons far to the east if she were to
be so foolish as to march on Westeros
she will not find as her ancestor Aegon
did seven disparate kingdoms frightened
by a strange beasts she will fire a
continent united behind Lord Tywin
Lannister who extinguished her own
father's flame and we have known dragons
now we have seen them die